tenemos dos triángulos rectángulos aquí
digamos que también sabemos que ambos
triángulos tienen un ángulo que en ambos
casos mide teta entonces el ángulo a es
congruente con el ángulo de y que es lo
que ahora sabemos de estos dos
triángulos pues para todo triángulo si
sabemos dos de sus ángulos podemos
conocer el tercer ángulo ya que la suma
de los ángulos internos de un triángulo
es igual a 180 grados por lo que si
tienes dos ángulos en común significa
que tienes los tres ángulos en común y
si tienes tres ángulos en común entonces
te estás enfrentando a triángulos
antes
aclaremos un poco más la situación
entonces este ángulo es teta y este es
90 juntos deben de sumar 180 grados por
lo que este ángulo más este ángulo de
aquí arriba deben de sumar 90 ya tenemos
los 90 de este ángulo entonces este
ángulo a y el b deben de ser ángulos
complementarios por lo que este ángulo
debe de ser
o venta
- z podemos utilizar la misma lógica de
este lado ya hemos usado 90 grados aquí
entonces tenemos otros 90 grados
restantes entre theta y ese ángulo
entonces este ángulo deberá de ser 90
grados menos
90 grados menos z
tenemos tres ángulos correspondientes
que son congruentes estamos frente a
triángulos semejantes y porque esto es
interesante pues sabemos gracias a la
geometría que la relación
correspondiente a los lados de un
triángulo siempre será la misma
entonces exploremos los lados
correspondientes bueno pues el lado que
más resalta cuando estás trabajando con
triángulos rectángulos es la hipotenusa
esta de aquí es la hipotenusa
esta hipotenusa va a corresponder a esta
otra hipotenusa de acá
podemos escribir esto
esta es la hipotenusa
de este triángulo y esta es la
hipotenusa de este otro triángulo
ahora este lado de aquí helado bc este
lado a cual corresponde pues si ves este
triángulo puedes ver a este lado como el
lado que está opuesto a este ángulo
theta es opuesto si cruzas el triángulo
llegas ahí entonces vamos al lado
opuesto del ángulo de yendo al lado
opuesto del ángulo a llegas a veces
yendo al lado opuesto del ángulo de
llegas a efe
llegas a efe que corresponde a este lado
justo aquí
y finalmente el lado hace ese lado
sobrante lo podemos ver como bueno hay
todos lados que forman este ángulo a uno
de ellos es la hipotenusa podemos llamar
a éste tal vez el lado adyacente a esta
entonces si te corresponde a entonces
éste debe de ser el lado que corresponde
la única razón por la que hice todo esto
fue para resaltar que la relación de los
lados correspondientes entre ángulos
semejantes siempre será la misma
por ejemplo la razón entre veces y la
hipotenusa de a déjame escribir esto
sobre
será igual
efe sobre f
efe
efe el largo del segmento f
sobre el largo del segmento d
sobre el largo del segmento ed
o también podemos escribir que el largo
del segmento hace
sobre la hipotenusa sobre la hipotenusa
de este triángulo sobre a b es igual a
df sobre ti otra vez este lado verde
sobre el lado naranja
estos son triángulos semejantes son
correspondientes uno al otro entonces
éste es igual a este es igual al de efe
sobre d
o también podemos decir podemos seguir
así pero solo haremos uno más o podemos
decir que la razón de este lado de aquí
el lado azul con el lado verde de este
triángulo
el largo de veces sobre sea sobre
será el mismo que la razón entre estos
dos lados correspondientes el azul sobre
el verde
efe
efe sobre de efe sobre t
efe y obtuvimos todo esto gracias al
hecho de que estos son triángulos
semejantes
entonces esto es cierto para todos los
triángulos semejantes o bueno esto es
verdad para cualquier triángulo
rectángulo que tenga un ángulo teta
entonces estos dos triángulos serán
semejantes y todas estas relaciones
seguirán siendo las mismas entonces tal
vez le podamos dar nombre a estas
relaciones basándonos en el ángulo theta
desde el punto de vista de theta desde
el punto de vista de theta escribiré
theta por aquí sólo para que lo
recuerden cuál es la relación de estos
dos lados
bueno pues desde el punto de vista de
teta
el lado azul es el lado opuesto es
opuesto entonces es el lado opuesto del
triángulo recto y el lado naranja ya lo
hemos etiquetado como la hipotenusa
entonces desde el punto de vista de
theta este es el lado opuesto
sobre la hipotenusa
y sigo viendo desde el punto de vista de
theta porque este no sería el caso desde
este otro ángulo para el ángulo b desde
el punto de vista de b este es el lado
adyacente sobre la hipotenusa pensaremos
en esta relación en otro momento ahorita
solo vemos desde el punto de vista de
teta que está aquí entonces desde el
punto de vista de teta que es esto
pues teta está aquí claramente ave y de
ave y de siguen siendo las hipotenusa y
que es hace que es hace y que es de f
pues éstas son adyacentes a theta son
uno de los dos lados que conforman a
este ángulo que no es la hipotenusa esto
lo podemos ver como la razón de
cualquiera de estos dos triángulos entre
el lado adyacente
y esto es relativo recordemos este es el
opuesto del ángulo b pero ahorita solo
estamos viendo al ángulo a el cual está
medido por theta o el ángulo de relativo
al ángulo a hace es adyacente relativo
al ángulo de de f es adyacente
entonces esta relación es el lado
adyacente sobre la hipotenusa
esta será la misma relación para
cualquier triángulo rectángulo que tenga
un ángulo theta y finalmente esta de
aquí esta será el lado opuesto este es
el lado opuesto esta relación para
cualquier triángulo rectángulo será el
lado opuesto sobre el lado adyacente
sobre el lado adyacente
y en realidad quiero resaltar la
importancia por lo que haremos muchos
muchos ejemplos para hacer esto muy
concreto ahora para cualquier triángulo
rectángulo que tenga un ángulo theta la
razón entre su lado opuesto y la
hipotenusa será la misma que la de otro
triángulo semejante como lo acabamos de
explicar la razón entre el lado
adyacente de este ángulo que es teta y
la hipotenusa será la misma para
cualquier cualquiera de estos triángulos
mientras que tenga el ángulo theta en el
y la razón relativa al ángulo theta
entre el lado opuesto y el lado
adyacente entre el lado azul y el verde
siempre será la misma
estos son triángulos semejantes
entonces dicho esto los matemáticos
decidieron darles nombre a estas
relaciones relativo al ángulo theta esta
razón siempre será igual así que la
llamaron el lado opuesto sobre la
hipotenusa lo llamaron el seno del
ángulo theta entonces este es el seno
y déjenme hacerlo en un color nuevo este
por definición y extender esta
definición en el futuro este es el seno
de theta este de aquí por definición es
el co seno
del ángulo theta y este de aquí por
definición es la tangente
del ángulo theta por definición es la
tangente del ángulo theta y una regla
nemotécnica que te ayudará a recordar
esto porque estás realmente son
definiciones la gente se dio cuenta de
aaa para tengo los semejantes esta razón
siempre será la misma
gracias a los triángulos semejantes para
cualquier ángulo theta esta razón
siempre será la misma esta razón siempre
será la misma entonces hagamos estas
relaciones definiciones y para ayudarnos
a recordarlas esta es la regla
nemotécnica solo que tohá lo escribiré
así show
su es
se no es opuesto sobre hipotenusa como
josé josé no es adyacente sobre
hipotenusa cosenos adyacentes sobre
hipotenusa y finalmente tangente
tangente es opuesto sobre yacente
tangente es opuesto opuesto sobre
opuestos sobre adyacente sow k2 en vinos
futuros aplicaremos estas estas
definiciones para estas funciones
trigonométricas